thanos is the biggest baddest villain
that we've seen in the MCU and quite
possibly in all of Marvel Comics history
as well from the first Avengers movie we
found out that Thanos was trying to
collect the Infinity stones then
throughout the years of the MCU we
watched Thanos hire other people to try
and collect the Infinity stones for him
that is until the events of age of
Ultron where we found out in the in
credit scene that he decided that he was
tired of everybody failing him and
decided to do it himself
and then in Avengers infinity work we
watch The Avengers try really really
hard to stop Danice but in the end it
wasn't enough
Thanos successfully collected all of the
Infinity stones and performed the
snapping Thanos the mad Titan finally
completed his goal but why is Thea knows
called the mad Titan where did this
nickname come from they slightly tell
his story in infinity war but I'll break
it down a little bit more for you also
another giveaway will be announced
tomorrow which is Saturday so if you'd
like to win a copy of infinity war
ant-man and the wasp or Deadpool - be
sure to enter for your chance to win by
subscribing to my channel liking the
video and commenting down below with
your favorite superhero so I've gotten
the question from many of you
why is Stannis called the mad Titan
which is a great question if you're not
familiar with the comics it is important
to note that they sort of changed Thanos
as origin in the MCU so the mad Titan
that I will be talking about is the MCU
version so they did make a tiny little
node to the comics of Thanos being
called the mad Titan in this scene right
here Titan was like most planets 20
mouths not enough to go around and when
we faced extinction I offered a solution
genocide but random his passion is fair
to rich and poor alike they called me a
madman and what I predicted came to pass
so as you heard Dana say they called him
a madman but that's usually what happens
when you suggest killing millions of
people director Joe Russo breaks the
scene down a little bit more Joe says
he's from a planet called Titan many
years prior to the film his planet was
experiencing a cataclysmic shift they
were running out of resources and they
were overpopulated Denis made a
recommendation that they exterminate
half the population randomly in order to
save the rest of the population of
course the Titans rejected his notion
branded him a madman exiled him and the
planet ended up dying so to put this in
simple terms the planet was running out
of food and resources to be able to feed
and support the people that lived on it
the people who lived on Titan were
called Titans Thanos included so Thanos
suggested killing half of the Titans
that lived on the planet in order to
save the other half this would mean that
they wouldn't run out of food and
resources and could grow more food but
it did involve killing half of an entire
planet which is a crazy idea it's insane
it's mad and he's a Titan so they called
him for the mad Titan but his planet
ended up dying and all of his people
ended up becoming extinct so he went
across the universe going planet to
planet killing half of the populations
on each planet and his name the mad
Titan followed him and who would be
known as this all across the universe
Thanos actually thinks that he's saving
the universe he thinks that if he
doesn't wipe out half of the universe
then everyone in the universe will
eventually die that's a lot better
reason than why he eliminates half of
the universe in the comics and the
comics Thanos performs the snappa named
for a woman that's right he kills half
of the universe in the comics for love
so you can see why they call him mad in
the comics so that's why Thanos is
called the mad Titan it's pretty simple
and they explain it a little bit in the
movie but I thought I'd explain it a
little bit more for those of you who
have been asking so let me know what you
think in the comments below and do you
think there was probably a better way
for Thanos to go about saving the
universe may be using the Infinity
Gauntlet to make more food seems like
mad Titan is a pretty fitting title but
let me know what you think in the
comments below and again picking a new
giveaway winner tomorrow on Saturday all
you have to do to enter for your chance
to win is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero as always thank you all so
much for watch
woof woof
[Music]